it was supposed to be the jewel in
Britain's manufacturing Crown our first
home-grown gigafactory co-financed by
the government turning out electric car
batteries from its plant in the
Northeast allowing this country to
compete with the rest of the world but
when British fault collapsed into
Administration earlier this year the
dream was left in tatters now in his
first TV interview since its implosion
the company's co-founder has told Sky
News that the government and
specifically Rishi sunak must take much
of the blame
there have been all these stories about
lots of money millions millions of
pounds spent on Executive salaries on
Consultants as well
lots of money spent on I think a kind of
like two three million pound Mansion for
executives to use
um yoga lessons as well remote from
Dubai when you put all of that together
can you see why people feel that you
know there was
there were question marks over the
management and whether there was value
for money given this was this was
taxpayers money that was potentially
going to be going into this company as
well so absolute rights
taking and breaking them down one by one
I think is very important
having a wellness instructor as a
preventative measure for People's Health
that is economical to be able to do that
virtually for 300 people at a low cost
of roughly two three thousand pounds a
month that is very economical when you
say Mansion for millions that was rented
for approximately a hundred thousand
pounds a year
that allowed us to constantly man that
house with over five to ten Executives
up in the Northeast don't forget British
world is a company that was born out of
covid so the team was scattered all over
UK
and it was a really really good team
because we had gathered the creme de La
Creme of UK talent in building the next
energy champion of you of of UK PLC but
a really good team a mansion but all for
a company that went insolvent it went
insolvent at the back end of a delayed
government grant sign off not an intent
as it was in January announced by number
10. I dab in between and proved it base
approved it it went all the way until
end of July early August it was signed
off why was that important from a market
sentiment from an investment sentiment
because it's an energy intense process
to produce batteries on top of
government grant we also need changes
within the energy policies of UK it is
such a much bigger picture than just
British Vault and the energy transition
for UK is so much more than ritual but
what a shame that British fault has been
that wake-up call because let's not
forget
quarter three quarter four
three different prime ministers
four different chancellors beginning of
2022 if you would say
during 22 UK will have inflation levels
close to what we had in 1955 last time
around
we will have geopolitical uncertainties
in Europe
last time that happened was 1945 and the
Second World War
interest rate spiking nobody had a
crystal ball
timing timing was of the essence and
unfortunately unfortunately Britain hit
38 billion
FDI deficit in quarter 4 2022 so all of
this
obviously was
a contributing factor so you've got the
economy the state of the economy yes
you've got the government and the fact
that the government wasn't giving you as
much money as you needed and how much
money as you were getting from overseas
were no you were getting less money from
overseas but it was the delay from
intent to sign off so the sign off that
richest United didn't do until the kind
of Forex at the last minute but then
that final factor of whether there was
mismanagement do you think that's a kind
of legitimate question there was no
misappropriation of fund because not a
single penny was spent on a private jet
100 000 went to a as you say a mansion
well it was a large house and if you
look at the cost of renting a hotel room
for that many people during that period
of time it was far more economical to
rent a house the fact that it happened
to have a pool that wasn't working for
18 months by the way it has nothing to
do with it okay so there's the Mansion
or the house or whatever one that wants
to call it there's many the millions of
pounds spent on Consultants as well at
the same time
the concern I think some people within
government and many I imagine in the
public have is just that
you were asking for quite a lot of
public money so taxpayers money
and there are concerns that not all of
that money would have been spent in as
disciplined away as they would have
liked do you think that's fair so every
single of taxpayer money was going to
equipment
was going to the hamsul facility or the
actual Giga plant up in the Northeast so
not to the mansion not to the consultant
definitely not to the mansion different
not to the Consultants the drawdown of
government money would have come
according to Milestones and kpis that
were pre-negotiated in 2021
and furthermore to build a gigafactory
is very very costly because you're
talking about a couple of million pounds
versus the total Capital four billion
pounds I see it did you get any
government money no so there's no
government money along the way no it was
all private money that you know up until
that point where it was wound down or
but it was sold off correct when we're
talking about lessons from the
experience so there's partly you say
there was an it was bad luck because
partly it was bad luck
partly it was the government wasn't bold
enough is that a fair kind of
characterization of what you're saying
in terms of how much money it was
willing to give they say it's a race for
Net Zero
a race means that we need to move fast
China has been moving fast for two
decades now
ipcei important projects of common
European interests was implemented
2015-16 and they started deploying
Capital already in 1718 in Europe in the
UK it took a 12-month due diligence
period first for Bayes and the civil
servants they did a sterling job because
the novel industry the civil servants
were fantastic
and then it was announced and then from
there it took six months of pure
bureaucracy for the government crime to
come out
as a final sign off why is that
important the Capital Market sentiment
as I've said before requires government
support because in the future we also
need changes in policy changes in energy
energy policies and changes there as an
example these are energy intense
processes for the financial model to
make sense
so it all goes hand in hand as I've said
in the past this is teamwork energy
transition building a gigafactory is not
just one man's job
we need another four of these
gigafactories in the UK
we had an impeccable team in place 300
strong British Minds that was ready for
industrialization that was ready to
start commercializing what we had been
building in the past two years don't
forget we've developed for the first
time in the UK since we invented the
lithium-ion battery we had the created
UK IP people claimed that we didn't have
a battery that's not correct we were
producing thousands of batteries that
were sold to Blue Chip oems in Europe
but it was all about timing if we would
have moved bit faster from government
perspective supported the proposition
with a final sign off when the intent
came in January from number 10
we would have caught the funding cycle
when FDI in the UK was positive
instead it was delayed and we fell into
a funding cycle that was negative we
need more money more funding was
required to push this proposition
forward how do you feel when you think
back and when you think of what might
have been do you feel
do you feel sad do you feel angry
shed Blood Sweat and Tears into this
the team was so passionate
we had one window of opportunity
to build a gigafactory and have that
ready by 25.
we've spent 70 million pounds on
enabling work onto the site in the
Northeast
another 20 30 million pounds on process
engineering
on designing it from an energy
perspective in order to build a low
carbon sustainable gigafactory
proposition this is where UK shines
the brightest Minds that come together
for two and a half three years
to build that first gigafactory instead
instead we lost that window of
opportunity now we're two years delayed
earliest earliest we can build a
gigafactory by 27.
imagine we already
are behind East Asia
we're already behind Continental Europe
UK unfortunately has lost out or is
losing out on a gigafactory economy
which is massive in terms of job
creation
on one end
if you look at the britual proposition
it was creating job in the midst of the
pandemic it was a positive FDI
contributor into the country but
unfortunately didn't see that same
support
from the conservative government in
order to level up the Northeast
because Northeast wasn't as important
for them
as maybe other places in this country
really British world we didn't get the
support that you felt you should have
got definitely not
at least not from a timing perspective
the civil servants were brilliant 12
months between January 21 and 22 they
did all their due diligences it was one
of the largest civil sermon due
diligence processes in her back then Her
Majesty's government's history that
British vote went through
but wear it but the the points you've
said a couple of times is
when it got to
Downing Street in particular when it got
to number 11 it just grant to a halt did
it so number 10 announced in January
intent to provide British food with 100
million pounds right
base approved and signed off
I double proven signed off it was
supposed to go to number 11 and come
back March April May June all of July
was stuck
at number 11. correct and who was
Chancellor at that point Richie right so
he has to Bear some responsibility for
for what happened if this was a if this
was a timing thing if you could have got
in earlier I think things would have
been different I don't think I don't
think uh Mr shunak
would look at it that way and nor do I
want to point the finger at anybody but
what I do know
keeps coming back to him yeah but it was
a major rivalry going on between Mr
Johnson and Mr shunak at that period of
time but if you're looking back at the
one thing that I think that could have
swung at I think which was collateral
damage stuck between a rock and a hard
place between Boris Johnson University
sooner the Rivalry between 10 and 11.
yes so you said you feel devastated
about what happened
do you you know do you feel any anger as
well and frustration about
the nature of how it happened nobody
could foresee a two-digit inflation that
the country hasn't seen since 1955 rise
in interest rates
nobody could foresee three different
Prime Ministers four different
chancellors UK saw a very turbulent time
and for a startup what is important is
that continuous Capital injection
and that really halted off and
unfortunately because of that rivalry we
were hit with the delay yeah do you
understand why some people who were
involved in British folk feel anger and
frustration themselves yeah about having
been in a project that you know they
were they were very committed to and has
emotional investment in and it didn't
come off yeah
I'm personally very very sad upset
devastated
the hope of a gigafactory and building a
gigafactory the dream of building a
gigafactory in the UK
unfortunately disappeared vanished Into
Thin Air and do you think this has done
damage to you know the hopes of others
who want to build these factories in the
UK unless UK changes his industrial
strategy
we will keep losing out on large-scale
projects arrival left the electric mini
left it's not just British Vault there's
a clear lack of industrial strategy
and feels like they're going towards the
right direction I keep hearing Rumblings
that jlr might come to Somerset I read
something in media that Jay Lord asked
for 500 million imagine British folk
couldn't even get 100 million but
they're choosing between Somerset and
Spain at the moment yes so the dreams of
having a gigafactory in the UK is
definitely there but then again giving
500 million to Tata and jlr how does
that help Aston Martin how does that
help Lotus how does that help other
propositions and other oems in the UK at
least British Vault was targeting to
service all of the oems not just one OEM
do you worry that when people look back
at this period in industrial history
that they'll look at British Vault and
that name will be associated with
failure rather than success I don't
think you will be especially when you
look backwards British what will be
Associated as a wake-up call for the
country I'm hearing the labor party
wanting to deploy 20 billion plus for
energy transition that would be
fantastic for UK economy as part of
re-industrialization that we haven't
seen since this statuary around this
country and that comes with investment
that requires investment to bridge that
funding gap which we've seen for from
from from from Europe and ipcei which
we've seen with the IRA and 370 billion
package in the US
when you look around the world it's
different governments and how they are
assisting their gov their battery
Industries what do you see there and
then what do you see in the UK
firstly speed
they're much more agile they're much
more Dynamic when today who who are you
talking about here
China has been for two decades uh Europe
is European union and the commission
Northfolk received over 700 million as I
said Germany as a country gave a private
company in Sweden 350 million government
guarantee for them to be able to free up
cash for the second project in Europe
that's unheard of
in modern Capital Market history that's
unheard of we've seen the IRA being
implemented in U.S that's 370 billion
package
they're acting much faster they're
deploying each project much much faster
coming back to timing again 12 months of
due diligence number 10 announces base
approves and signs off I double proofs
and signs off it takes another six
months for number 11 to sign off
I don't see this as efficient so too
slow but the size is the is the UK
ambitious enough on size
uh I would say the labor
uh proposition and proposal is far more
closer to what the rest of the world is
doing
compared to the industrial strategies
that we have in place three and for
those people who look at this and say
why are all these private companies so
reliant on government assistance
couldn't they just survive on their own
two feet what's the response to that
it's a capex heavy exercise it's a
Industrial
investment it's the industrial project
large-scale industrial project we need
to come at least into the the kind of 14
15 16 gigawatt hours in order to reach
economies of scale for these projects
that comes with the funding requirement
of 1.5 billion and above
why do you have ipci implemented in
Europe imported projects are common
European interest
in order to bridge that funding Gap what
has China been doing for the past two
decades they have been bridging that
funding Gap
it is not possible to set up a
gigafactory without any government
support it's not possible it does not
make economic sense
however it doesn't mean maybe the UK
shouldn't be doing it at all but it's a
necessity as part of the energy
transition
there is no energy transition without
gigafactories there is no energy
transition without batteries and just
the car industry oh for the car industry
in particular as we're moving away from
Ice internal combustion engine towards
this year of EVs and immobility
at trees or quintessential in in this
transition and we need assistance and we
need to bridge these gaps these gaps
just like any other country is doing in
the rest of the world either you've
waited quite a while before before kind
of coming out and talking publicly did
you just need some time to kind of think
about things you know a lot of people
have heard from from from other sources
about British faults but why are we
hearing from you now do you think so I
left the company in August and once I
stepped down I was no longer the CEO I
was no longer on the board
and I had to respect and allow my
colleagues at British vault
to work and do what they needed to do
unfortunately the team that was left
behind it was a team that was focused on
industrialization
he wasn't a team that was focused on how
to uh centered around managing Global
recessions unheard of global recessions
these were teams of Engineers
these were teams of Engineers that would
build a low carbon sustainable
gigafactory proposition the creme de La
Creme of UK
they were not politicians they were not
bankers and they hit the perfect storm
of recession a multi-layered recession
unheard of unlike any other recession
we've seen in modern Capital markets the
2008 recession was subprime focused the
early 2000 recession was I.T bubble
focused this time around
inflation geopolitical uncertainty that
led to an energy crisis Rising interest
rates multi-layered recession
this is the first time you've spoken
post the collapse of British Vault about
what happened
does it feel like cathartics would be
talking about it now
I'm still I'm still devastated when I
talk about British vault
the team put in Blood Sweat in tears
Blood Sweat and Tears
the activity levels on emails were
amazing incredible
the HR department
used to tell me it's incredible how
passionate everybody is about this
project emails were flying around two
three four a.m every day
seven days a week
we really really lost out on the
opportunity of building a gigafactory in
the UK really unfortunately lost have an
opportunity
and and the the 38 billion deficit
on FDI that we saw in quarter four
twenty twenty two is I think
self-explanatory why do they still
matter do they do they still matter does
it still matter for the UK to be pushing
to have more gigafactories in future
I think
UK needs to build not one not two
according to APC we need to build four
gigafactors by 2030. do they still
matter yes they're essential for the
energy transition there is no energy
transition without batteries
nor is it enough but we couldn't just
import them from China could we rules of
origin are being implemented 2027 in
Europe so that means that even if you
import a cathode of the battery from
China and assemble it on the shores of
Continental Europe or UK you would still
be hit with a 10 tariff
but let me pause you another question
then Ed and think about this if the
lithium-ion phosphate lfp battery is
equivalent to the diesel especially for
the last mile delivery if the nmc the
high kind of energy density nickel
manganese Cobalt type batteries are RR
for the kind of sports car industry or
or the luxury car industry but
that reminds me in a very basic term
Diesel and petrol
do we want to have full dependency of
all of our Diesel and petrol to China
does that not cause an energy security
issue for the country
that's the issue is it so it's it comes
down to being able to have that energy
Independence or the security that's why
they implemented the rules of origin in
the first place because it's a major
major energy security issue if Tata
chose Spain rather than the UK would you
be surprised I hope they choose the UK I
hope that the government will give them
at least two 300 million pounds and I
hope that the government will actually
go in and change legislation and
policies around energy
and bring
the jlr or the Tata facility to the UK
but is that enough though we have more
oems besides jlr in the UK Tata would
just be producing for themselves so we
still need more even after that who's
going to service Aston Martins of this
world who's going to service the lotuses
of this world even if these are small
small numbers but put them all together
what would have happened if arrival
would have stayed who would have who who
would have been been supplying a rival
what about Teva another fantastic
company in the UK who would be supplying
Teva
we do still have hopes of homegrown
gigafactory in terms of anti but that's
more niche market that's more sodium ion
type of batteries that doesn't go
towards the EV side of things and then
become reliant on what Continental
Europe but Continental Europe is seeing
a deficit in terms of supply and demand
they're only seven gigafactories in
Europe compared to the 118 in China we
need to build another 10 15 of them in
Europe but that's going to be all eaten
up by domestic demand and then on top of
that for True energy transition for True
Net Zero targets
we also need to buffer our grids as we
move towards the renewable energy
sources the sun doesn't shine all the
time
so we need static and stationary energy
storage again batteries
the wind doesn't blow all the time
so again we need to buffer the grids
with stationary aesthetic energy storage
in extension a Natural Evolution home
wall batteries again we need batteries
as part of this energy Insurance
always comes back to batteries there is
no energy transition without batteries
we asked the government for comment
about Mr najari's allegations that the
treasury and in particular Rishi sunac
delayed the grant money that might have
saved British fault for nearly six
months a spokesperson said these claims
are completely untrue taxpayer money
must always be used responsibly which is
why full due diligence was undertaken
before a final Grant offer was made the
grant offer which was welcomed and
accepted by the company included an
agreement that funds could only be drawn
when agreed Milestones are met such as
those on securing private Investments
unfortunately those conditions were not
met and despite significant engagement
from government a solution was not found
the government remains committed to
leveling up across the UK and is
actively engaging with companies to
secure Investments that will ensure the
UK remains a world leader in automotive
Manufacturing
the problem according to insiders from
both camps is that the British fault
experience may have undermined
confidence in gigafactories altogether
it might mean government is now more
reluctant to put public money into these
projects but without these factories the
fate of Britain's car industry is
increasingly under question